à quelques semaines du trail d'efforts
et son lien direct avec cette
compétition de masse des adolescents et
des adultes ont participé cet après midi
à un travail original une distance
réduite 8 kilomètres et demi 200 m de
dénivelé et des objectifs qui vont bien
au delà de la performance physique
individuelle dans chaque équipe de 3,1
adolescents déficients intellectuels
légers
c'est la première fois que l'un qui est
un petit peu c'est difficile notre
iginla ben si les kilomètres sans que ça
va mais pendant que c'est pas plus mais
autrement mais on a un peu le trac tous
ça permet de les mettre en valeur
ça leur permet aussi de ce mal de se
revaloriser de gagner de la confiance en
eux pour les organisateurs élèves de
terminale de la maison familiale et
rurale de mort l'épreuve comptera pour
le baccalauréat pour tous est un moment
de partage et de solidarité
le trail c'est dur mais toujours plus
facile avec de l'entr'aide toi tu aime
le sport temps faire genre général tu
fais quoi table du foot tu as vu tonnes
et le trail c'est la première fois
autrefois cantonnée à quelques
disciplines sportives les déficients
intellectuels légers ont accès à presque
tous les sports avec les mêmes bienfaits
que pour tout le monde c'est vraiment un
élément moteur pour eux ça va permettre
vraiment de d'avancé que ce soit sur
leur motricité leur petit motricité
leurs capacités physiques est leur état
de santé global et ça va vraiment leur
permettre d'avancer même dans la vie de
tous les jours et comme souvent
entrailles l'arrivée est parfois
difficile mais toujours avec la
satisfaction de l'effort accompli
des fêlures